eine heftige gasexplosion in einer
hamburger schule und das am tag der
zeugnisse das büro des schulleiters und
das lehrerzimmer wurden vollständig
zerstört
er passiert ist es in den frühen
morgenstunden an der schule in
finkenwerder um 344 wurde die feuerwehr
alarmiert und als die rettungskräfte
anrücken da stand das gebäude schon
komplett in flammen sie sehen dort die
bilder die zerstörung ja es gab offenbar
noch kleinere explosionen im keller der
schule das sagt die feuerwehr ja
eigentlich heute zeugnisübergabe jetzt
ermittelt aber das lka schule fällt dort
sehen sie diese bilder heute natürlich
erstmal aus ja einen tag denn auch der
schulleiter nicht so schnell vergessen
wird eigentlich hätte es nämlich nicht
nur zeugnisse gegeben heute ist auch der
letzte tag für den schulleiter steffen
kirsch meinen abgang mit knall
schief gelaufen
das programm sie kommen ist er nicht nur
der letzte zug dafür die schüler
überlegen gewesen aber auch beim
persönlich halte der vorstand dem
ausstand haben wir natürlich nicht übrig
hätte er gerade nochmal hier geraten
haben
sich vernünftig verabschieden
[Musik]
reporter markus hinzu für uns vor ort
marco sagt uns einmal wie sieht es jetzt
am morgen dort aus und wie kriegen die
schüler ihre zeugnisse
ja also die man sieht dass hier hinter
mir ist das zerstörte gebäude es ist
liegt in schutt und asche das ist das
büro der stellvertretenden schulleiterin
und wir haben gerade feuerwehrkräfte
hier vor ort erzählt heute nacht flogen
hier tatsächlich die ganzen zeugnisse
hin und her und sind natürlich alle
eingesammelt worden aber ja die
zeugnisse sind digitalisiert also von
daher die zeugnis geben und ja die
retter sind hier immer noch bei
löscharbeiten beschäftigt und jain drin
ist alles kaputt was man denn schon
irgendwelche hintergründe dazu wie es
dazu kommen konnte
also vermutet wird tatsächlich eine
gasexplosion wie das jetzt zu dieser
explosion kommen konnte das klärt jetzt
das lka die spezialisten vom lka 45 von
der polizei hamburg sind hier vor ort
und werden jetzt sich das gebäude und
die gasleitung natürlich genau anschauen
er wirklich ihre bilder die wir da aus
hamburg die uns da aus hamburg heute
morgen erreichen vielen dank marco
zitzow für deine aktuelle information
sobald es dazu neuigkeiten gibt werden
wir natürlich wieder zu dir zurück
kommen dankeschön